our next guest has a single googly eye whereas a
lentil is a hat and is a shell oh yeah with Shoes
On We're talking about Marcel the Shell since
his YouTube debut that was back in 2010 his
videos have been viewed listen to this number 50
million times now his first movie is nominated for
the Academy Award for best animated feature wow
Marcel the Shell with Shoes On follows Marcel's
as it follows Marcel as he attempts to find his
long-lost family in this clip Marcel reacts to
comments on his video after it goes viral you
know there's nothing in here about finding them
there's so much nothing he's the best see what
but my dad has pink shoes so do my grandfather
so cute
peace uh yeah obviously peace like what
a weird thing to try to test to see if
someone else is into like of course I'm
into peace no sorry I'm a real war person
no war actually I signed all my personal
letters War let the battle begin Marcel
Marcel the Shell is making his very first TV
appearance we're very happy to say we got him
his voice and co-creator actor and comedian
Jenny slate is also with us Jenny good to see
you too first on CBS mornings first let's start
off congratulations and Oscar nomination when you
and your your partner at the time Dean Fisher Camp
decided came up with his character You couldn't
possibly have dreamed of an Oscar nomination no
certainly not so so what were you guys trying
to do well I was just doing this silly little
voice that I started doing one weekend when we
were sharing a hotel room with a bunch of friends
and trying to save some money and um I had spent
the last year on SNL just like trying to do any
voice or face that I could do I kind of thought I
had nothing left but then this little voice popped
out and Dean had promised a friend of ours that he
would make a short film for their live comedy show
in Brooklyn and he hadn't done it yet and we were
he was sort of like uh can I interview that voice
that you're doing and maybe I'll make something
and that's just how it started yeah it's like you
think what do I have to offer and you go hey it's
my voice yeah so then you get nominated for number
one how did you find out you were nominated what'd
you think um there were a lot of text messages
that came in I had been up all night with my
daughter I just gone to sleep so you weren't
watching the nomination I was not no and I I sort
of uh yeah I just try to let things roll through
I guess but I got a lot of text messages from my
sisters and I was like oh I think they're probably
texting to say you know better luck next door yeah
like why didn't they call but in fact um it was
my family not wanting to wake me up and texting to
say congrats and then our producer Elizabeth Holm
called me and I shed a tear but not too loudly
because I didn't want to wake up the baby people
experience Marcel there's there's this sense of
Joy yeah um almost childlike wonderment you have
it's like you're reliving your own childhood what
does Marcel mean to you well I think there is
that but something that maybe happens to some
of us is that when we're young we're allowed
to wonder and we're allowed to experiment and
we're allowed to assess our emotions as they're
happening because they're new sometimes for the
first time and then kind of gets like shamed or
just somehow like we lose it yes and one of the
best things I think about being an adult is that
you have all the freedom that you didn't have as
a child you have the opportunity to try to get
back that wonder and I do think that is one of
the many things that this character means to me
is like really the opportunity to get inside of
that feeling of like every day is new I want to be
alive in my life as I'm living it and feel it and
um that's how I try to live too yeah me too how
did you decide on his look because he's not the
cutest thing he's a little quirky looking oh a
seashell a seashell a seashell with shoes how
did you decide on his look and his voice I think
he's you can't your voice a little bit Marcel's
just chilling by the way yes yeah he's here
and Nate notices he has to see PBS morning's
mother well he must he must well actually Dean
Fleischer Camp is the one who completely came
up for the character design um he took a bunch of
found objects that we had in our house and there
were a few different prototypes there were like
some other weird little guys that didn't really
make the grade but he created Marcel he stuck
the eye in there and put it on the side of our
kitchen table and I came into the house and
he said I think he's here and I looked and I
saw him and I said oh that's definitely and I
actually think that he's very handsome you do
I do I think he's very few then I take it back
he's very handsome what you I called quirky you
call handsome yeah this is the thing Leslie Stahl
makes an appearance I was watching the movie and
they referenced Leslie Stahl the 16-minute show
so I recorded it and sent it to Leslie I go Leslie
this is the cutest thing if you're not aware of it
they mention you they call you classic blah blah
blah little did I know that Leslie's through line
throughout the movie is 60 minutes so then I felt
stupid with two o's because I said if you're not
aware and Leslie Stone 60 Minutes play a big role
in this movie oh yeah too yes love it so much
she showed up to set I'm ready to do this she
fully interviewed me I was in character as Marcel
sitting on the floor yes um and also she was so
lovely because weirdly at that time I had hurt my
back and I was kind of like lying on the floor and
she emailed me to make sure I was okay afterwards
but yeah she completely jumped into my project
um and like Dean and I and Nick Paley our
co-writer um just really wanted her from
the start we never no they call it the Leslie
show they called 60 minutes yeah the best line
to me in the movies when Marcel says I'm the
best of myself when I'm connected to everything
um so can uh Gail and I be in the sequel Marcel
too I mean how could I say no yes you can't to our
face what is your daughter what does your daughter
think about Marcel she really likes Marcel I don't
think she knows that I'm Marcel really um I
do the voice for her but I don't think she
understands yeah yeah that it's you know but one
day can you do Marcel can you read the prompter
in Marcel's voice that'd be okay no no yeah what
should I say Jenny slate Mars oh oh sell the show
you look at that thank you